luke here with the outdoor boys youtube
channel and i've got something pretty
fun planned for you guys today i'm gonna
try to catch massive catfish on this
stand-up paddleboard and to do it i've
gotta float
this river
me and jake are out here looking for
worms we got to get ourselves some bait
yeah there's a big big juicy one
all right there you go
look at that
is that cool this is a little ring neck
snake oh here's the big one
there you go look for a place where the
leaves are wet oh there's you right
there there's another one
there we go
another snake
there's one
jake's got one i think we got plenty of
worms there
and then we're gonna just take a left
[Music]
i love you babe i'll see you tomorrow
okay
yeah we're gonna do an overnight fishing
floating trip and we're going to see if
we can't catch some big fish
i've never done rapids on a stand-up
paddleboard this is going to be
interesting
well so far so good that worked out
pretty well
the creek's kind of shallow here so i
took the fin off the paddle board but it
makes me want to spin around
keeps trying to send me down backwards
oh we got a little river treasure here
oh there we go
i think we got a carp down here oh yep
there he is you can see the bubbles and
the mud being kicked up
oh we got a little problem up ahead
looks like we got a bit of a blockage
that wasn't exactly graceful but it
worked out
i got covered in all these spiderwebs
with these dead flies in
it well this trip is off to a little bit
of a rough start i just dropped my gopro
mount in the water i gotta go see if i
can dive for it and find it
oh
i think it's gone
it's not exactly a warm day today
well now that i'm in the water i might
as well put my fin on my board
well i'm soaking wet i'm a little bit
cold and now i have to hold my camera
while i try to paddle and fish and do
everything on we go
well i managed to fit my selfie stick
into the scupper hole of my board and it
seems to be working pretty well as a
diy gopro mount
trying to get my bottom to dry out so
i'm standing up and paddling but it's
making the camera wiggle like this
looks like we got some moving water up
ahead hopefully i didn't put my fit on
too soon
oh thank goodness we're getting some sun
i'm freezing
[Music]
oh this looks a little sketchy
[Music]
that's all that's left of my fin that
last set of rapids was a bit shallow and
just destroyed my fin this is turning
out to be an expensive trip
i'm gonna eat some wheat thins to make
myself feel better
i just saw some bluegill jumping along
the side of the creek so i'm going to go
ahead and try to catch some bait so i
want to catch the bait fish like the
bluegill or the sunfish and they're all
going to be up against these steep banks
where there's lots of overhanging
vegetation
i already got a bite
there we go that's perfect that's
exactly what we want to catch
[Music]
all right let's go get some more of
those
there we go basically just a little bit
of worm in a number 10 eagle claw hook
and a bobber
all right we got a couple google we're
just going to keep going downstream see
what happens
well things have slowed down a little
bit i'm gonna see if i can't catch some
more bait
a little green sunfish right there
there we go
nice looking little spot here we're
gonna see if we can pick up bluegill
yep
all right there we go
take this out that's a pawpaw it's the
largest wild native fruit in north
america whenever you find them they're a
real treat
see look at that
oh it smells great oh smells like a mix
between banana and mango
oh this one's so good
they have these big seeds in them
this one is so perfectly ripe
literally one of my favorite fruits oh i
could eat like a hundred more of those
oh check it out a papa tree
so this is a papa tree it's got these
really big distinct leaves almost looks
like some sort of tropical plant but
it's got these really big fruit growing
on the stems uh these ones are still
hard they're not ripe yet a papa should
be mushy like a ripe banana
here's a good one
oh this one's pretty good paw paws are
like bananas if they're too pretty
they're not ripe you want ones that are
beat up a little bit
oh look at that
that one's yeah
oh
that's a good one
oh here's another one oh that's gonna be
a big beauty it's another paw paw tree
there papa tree there
oh well that's a good one
oh i'm loving this but i've got to make
tracks i got them running out of time
oh look there's another papa tree right
there man there's just piles of them in
here
check it out here's another one of my
favorite edible plants this is the
autumn olive tree right here and look at
how many berries there are on this bush
it's just absolutely insane with berry
this is an invasive plant that loves
lots of sunshine so you'll find them on
the edges of rivers bike paths roads
look at this you just pick like that
and boom look at all these berries it's
a really distinct berry it's red with
yellow dots it's like a red currant or a
cranberry it's really tart and they call
them autumn olives because they have a
pit inside that looks a lot like an
olive pit but every fall me and my boys
we go and harvest autumn olives and we
make fruit leather and jam and soda pop
out of autumn olives i've got tons of
videos on it
oh i'm not as far along as i wanted to
be it's about an hour or two before
sunset and this is when i should be
fishing for catfish oh i better shut up
and get paddling
oh there's a big carp right there sun's
starting to set and the fish are getting
really active i'm going really quiet
along the shore here and there's lots of
carp
see right there that disturbance in the
water that's a big carp feeding as the
sun starts to get low the carp get brave
and get in shallow
ah i am getting crazy hungry i think i
need to pull over and find a spot to
make some dinner
oh my butt hurts
i've been paddling for about six and a
half hours and did about nine miles oh
i'm a little sore
ooh cherry blueberry cobbler
i'm gonna try some blueberry cobbler
here it's like blueberry flavored
gelatin but i'll take it
beef patty grilled with jalapeno peppers
mustard ketchup and a tortilla this is
an mre heater you put a little fresh
water in this pouch and it reacts with
chemicals and gives off a lot of heat
warms up your food
the food and the heat are in here
this is an abomination jalapeno beef
patty bacon cheddar cheese product and
ketchup on a tortilla good
man i'm hungry
time for some dessert oatmeal cookie
it just got dark real quick i think it's
time to go try to catch some big old
catfish
all right guys check it out i mounted
these waterproof bicycle lights onto my
boat
that is 1 000 lumens and it'll last 12
hours there the battery packs back here
you got one over here too
yeah we can we can see really good now
all right
all right i got two bluegill casted out
there and i'm just playing the waiting
game i can slam a 40 pound catfish or a
four pound catfish okay we got a fish
we're going for a bit of a ride this
fish is dragging the boat around
am i trying to keep my balance on this
paddle board
and he is pulling us around oh look at
this
oh boy
that is a big blue catfish i am worried
about tipping
i am terrified he's gonna knock me into
the water
oh
oh that's about 30 pounds right there
there's a chunky 30 pound blue catfish
whoa
that was exhilarating and terrifying
that catfish hit so hard definitely
gotta you gotta play it smart and keep
your drag loose or you're gonna go for a
swim but that was fun i think we should
go try to get another one
[Music]
oh there he goes oh look at that got a
big one we got a big one right here look
at that he's just swinging the boat
around
oh
huge channel yeah
get back in there troublemaker
nice channel catfish
another beautiful channel catfish well
that was our last live bluegill so
now we're going to try some cut bait
another beautiful channel catfish
it is late and i'm completely out of
bait but what a great time now i need to
find a spot to camp so i'm gonna go and
paddle for about a mile or two in the
dark
and try to go see if i can find my
campsite it's gonna it's gonna be
interesting
all right i think this is the spot i
gotta poke around a little bit and see
if i could find a nice flat dry spot to
set up my tent
there we go got my tent set up
got my quilt my mat it's close to
midnight and i am exhausted so i am just
gonna go straight to bed and i'm gonna
see you guys in the morning
oh i'm tired
it's just cold enough outside i don't
want to get out of bed
got a really simple breakfast here i got
my favorite cereal a little bit of
powdered milk some dehydrated
raspberries add about two cups of water
to this shake it up we're gonna have
breakfast
well i got breakfast in my belly so i'm
not gonna dawdle i'm gonna break camp
and get out of here because uh
i got a lot of miles to paddle
look how tiny that is that's my sleeping
quilt
there you go that's my tent it's the
z-pack two-man freestanding tent weighs
just a little over one pound
[Applause]
oh my butt hurts i sat on this bucket
for about 10 11 hours yesterday and my
butt's a little sore and i just sat down
on it oh and my butt didn't like that i
gotta get some pad for this thing
well last night i ended up not getting
as far as i wanted to and cut into my
fishing time so today i'm gonna be
really diligent and i'm going to try to
get all my paddling out of the way so
that we can do some fishing tonight
check out another amazing native fruit
this is a persimmon tree and another one
of my favorite fruits it's another fruit
that's really tricky to get it just
right but when it's ripe it's so
good
now you can see this one here has got a
gypsy moth infestation here see these
little persimmon fruit right here when
they're ripe they turn orange
see this one's
oh yeah this one's doing pretty good
right here so this right here is a wild
persimmon and the flesh tastes like
honey and cinnamon it's just one of the
most delightful fruit now some people
who try wild persimmons have a bit of a
bad experience because the skin has this
white
waxy residue on it and that residue
tastes like deodorant it's this bitter
nasty flavor that gets stuck to your
tongue it's it's not good
you can scrub and wash the outside to
try to get that wax off or you can just
take your fingernail and get rid of the
skin
take the top off and you have this
little gooey bit
oh
so good it's like there's this flowery
flavor with it too it's like there's
honey and rose and
cinnamon in it
so good and inside it's got these big
pits about the size of a pumpkin seed
just don't eat the skin and it's the
most amazing thing ever
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
um
[Music]
oh
my back and butt are so sore but i made
it and i'm excited because tonight i'm
getting on my stand up paddle board and
i'm going to go out here into this swamp
and we're going to hunt enormous snake
heads
i'm so excited this is something i've
wanted to do for a long time they're
crazy delicious and it's enormous fun
but before i can do that i've got to go
home take some advil and get a new gopro
mount oh look who's here
oh
my boy
this is my fishing spear i hand forged
it a couple years ago and it is a fish
killing machine
now we just gotta wait for the sun to
set
that shad just hit the boat
all right i just missed one
well the visibility was pretty terrible
i could only see about a foot and a half
two feet in the water managed to swallow
a load of bugs though but listen i'm
gonna call it for the night and if you
guys want to see more videos where i go
out spear fishing from paddle boards
check out the video description below
i'll put links to some of my previous
videos if you guys want to see more
videos from the outdoor boys youtube
channel make sure to click subscribe we
put out new videos every saturday
morning thanks for watching guys
ah oh
bugs if you like this video don't forget
to check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every saturday morning and hit
that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching
[Music]